the Joker is unquestionably one of the
greatest villains in the history of
comic books unfortunately though the
characters track record outside the
comics hasn't exactly been spotless with
over a dozen major appearances and TV
movies and video games the varied
interpretations of the Clown Prince of
Crime have cast a pretty wide net from
amazing to terrible
he is our ultimate guide to every
version of the Joker ranked from worst
to best
Scooby Doo Joker despites coming in dead
last on our list the version of the
Joker that appeared on the new
scooby-doo movies isn't unforgivably
terrible
he's just flat-out boring which might be
an even bigger problem plus he's a
complete failure as he can't manage to
even scare scooby-doo a character
defined by being terrified of everything
[Music]
the only thing that's worth mentioning
about him is that he was voiced by
veteran comedian and actor Larry Storch
and let's be real here
that's only interesting if you're the
kind of person who likes to get into
some hardcore trivia about the cast of F
Troop the new adventures of Batman Joker
if you want to develop a whole new
appreciation for Batman the Animated
Series take some time to head back to
1977 for the new Batman adventures which
features some of the worst character
redesigns ever amazingly the Joker who
was voiced by Lenny Weinreb managed to
escape that particular flaw in the show
but he looks a lot like he does in the
comics is about the only good thing you
can say about him his major
accomplishment during the show's entire
16 episode run was losing an election
for president of criminals when the
penguin invented a mind-altering
substance called crime-slime if he can't
win an election against the penguin what
are you even doing son of Batman Joker
in all honesty we only included the
Bradley Baker's turner's to Joker on
this list in order to be as thorough as
we can that's not to knock the guy but
as the Joker's appearance and son of
Batman is limited to appearing as a
shadow on a wall and the letting out one
laugh
but it was a nice laugh at least
Superfriends Joker the superfriends saga
ran for eight years and the various
titles but the Joker only ever appeared
once when the show was commonly known as
the super powers team in 1985 so
wildcards where he was voiced by Frank
Welker unfortunately his appearance was
both minor and bizarre with the Joker
turning up as part of the playing card
themed supervillain team at the Royal
Flush gang he's not the team's Joker
though he's actually disguised as the
ace if your story calls for a
chalk-white villain named after a
playing card to dress up as a different
chalk-white villain named after a
playing card things are getting a little
needlessly complicated young justice
Joker
you know those memes where they
intentionally mix a bunch of geeky
franchises in order to induce nerd rage
well the Young Justice version of the
Joker feels a lot like the ladies and
gentlemen we interrupt your regularly
scheduled me he's the Joker but he looks
like David Tennant as the doctor and is
voiced by brent Spiner from Star Trek
The Next Generation it's not exactly
terrible but it's overshadowed by just
about every other version of Joker ever
Lego Batman DC superheroes unite Joker
if you enjoyed the big screen Lego
Batman movie then we have good news and
bad news the good news is there's
already a second Lego Batman movie you
can watch and in fact has been available
on a home video since 2013 but here's
the bad news
it's actually just a collection of
cutscenes from the Lego Batman 2 a DC
superheroes video game thrown in with a
few new scenes to recreate the events
that happens when you actually play the
game all edited into a 71 minute movie
it's actually not that bad and
Christopher Corey Smith gives a solid
voice performance even if it is just a
standard ref on Mark Hamill's Joker
the Dark Knight Returns Joker to say the
role of the Joker in an animated version
of Frank Miller's classic The Dark
Knight Returns presented a challenge is
putting things pretty mildly the
characters arc went from catatonic to
insanely murderous requiring a ton of
range Person of Interest star Michael
Emerson gave it two shots but played it
just a little to flare - during the
first parts of the Joker's journey at
the end he ramps up to a satisfying
fever pitch but this one is a little too
uneven to rank any higher Lego Batman
video games Joker Steve bloom became the
first voice actor to voice both Batman
and the Joker in the first Lego Batman
game but that accomplishment comes with
an asterisk because he had almost no
dialogue
that changed in the second and third
games where the game's designers decided
to expand the dialogue in order to tell
a more complex and rewarding story bloom
was replaced by Troy Baker for the role
of Batman but stayed on as the Joker
turning in a fine performance heavily
influenced by Mark Hamill
in my sugar shut up
DC Superfriends sure to Joker when
you're hiring someone to play the Joker
it stands to reason that two of the most
important qualifications are going to be
a morbid sense of humor and an insanely
creepy laugh if that's the case you
could do a hell of a lot worse than just
going out and getting the guy who played
the Cryptkeeper on Tales from the Crypt
that's exactly what happened in 2010
when john kassir lent his voice to a
series of shorts packaged with fisher
prices line of Superfriends toys Casilla
does a good job of mixing up his
performance though it's still instantly
recognizable to anyone who was a fan of
the 80s HBO anthology which probably did
not include any of the kids in the
target audience
we hope the superfriends Joker the Joker
were given in DC Super Friends is pretty
great if only because of how much he
clearly hates working with the other
super villains voice actor Lloyd Floyd's
audible eye-rolling add some fun new
ones to a performance that's otherwise
pretty much by the book but hey he does
get bonus points for not copying Mark
Hamill like so many others have done
I thought you had no sense of humor gold
card you was a lab accident Suicide
Squad Joker first you have to get past
the design that starts with a tattoo of
the word damaged on his forehead and
that just spirals out from there until
he looks like he should be performing
alongside Dark Lotus at this year's
gathering of the Juggalos then you have
to get past all those stories of Jared
Leto going method and sending his
co-stars live rats dead pigs and used
condoms what you're left with is well
not much of anything really
for all the hype surrounding letõs
appearance as the Joker in Suicide Squad
it pretty much amounted to about ten
minutes of screen time that were mostly
there for Harley Quinn's origin story
and some ill-advised fanservice
Arkham origins Joker when Arkham City
was announced as Mark Hamill's final
outing as the Joker there was a pretty
big problem as Batman's arch nemesis the
Clown Prince of Crime was definitely
going to be in the next game which told
the story of an encounter much earlier
in Batman's career
thus the role of the Joker fell to Troy
Baker and the problem here is obvious he
pretty much just did a dead-on
impression of Hamill's Joker for the
entire game
to be fair he actually does a really
good job of it but a copy is just never
going to beat the original
[Music]
gotham's Jerome Valeska the people
behind Gotham clearly know that they
can't really have the Joker show up
years before Bruce Wayne becomes Batman
on account of his origin story being so
tightly intertwined so they just went
ahead and created a guy who isn't
technically the Joker but is definitely
a maniacal supervillain with a permanent
rictus grin who dresses as a circus
clown and ones to sow chaos wherever he
can Cameron Monaghan's performances
Tyrone Valeska is ridiculously
compelling and has made for some pretty
wild television Arkham series Joker
first things first the Arkham franchise
has produced some of the best video
games in recent memory and without
question the best Batman games ever
unfortunately even though they got the
legendary Mark Hamill to do the voice
for three out of four
they also ended up giving us a joker who
has what might be the single stupidest
master plan in the characters 75 year
history
seriously after perfectly executing his
scheme he unveils his ultimate master
stroke which is turning himself into a
giant drug monster and getting in a
fistfight with the greatest hand-to-hand
fighter in the world really dude
dumb things like this are why you never
be Batman I can take the Batman Joker
the redesign of the Joker for the Batman
is remembered as one of the most
divisive missteps in the history of DC
animation laboring under the shadow of
the legendary Batman the Animated Series
and stuck with the task of incorporating
the batwave gimmick of the accompanying
toy line designer Jeff Matsuda decided
to go as far in the opposite direction
as possible from Bruce Tim's a sleek
design from Batman the Animated Series
the results or wasn't very well received
to put it mildly but Kevin Michael
Richardson zhh take on the Joker
actually had some really good stories
such as the luffing but where Joker
becomes a vigilante and uses joke venom
to turn Batman into a bad guy so he has
a super villain to fight that's pretty
awesome
Rafi T
that's a pretty serious offense girls
but that's why I became a crime fighter
to take her garbage like you leggo
Gotham City breakout Joker sometimes the
Joker is a sinister psychopathic
murderer and then other times he's a
goofy and delightfully manipulative
weirdo who brings down an entire city
armed only with a spoon Joker stories
that are actually funny are pretty rare
these days so having a version of the
Joker was whimsical as JSON speed sacks
take on the character is a rare treat
and the fact that this short also
introduced his sidekick Spoony it's a
hilarious bonus spoonie that's not even
a real superpower perhaps a
demonstration for school Batman return
of the caped crusaders Joker Adam West
Burt Ward and Julie Newmar returns to
the roles of Batman Robin and Catwoman
in Batman return of the Caped Crusader's
that was great but the rest of the cast
was given the enviable task of playing
specific versions of characters
identified with actors who had died
years before for Jeff Bergman that meant
playing Cesar Romero playing the Joker
it was a high-wire act as Bergman had to
be respectful of both Ramiro and Ramirez
take on the Joker but a Bergman nailed
it in a performance that feels like a
true tribute Batman The Brave and the
bold Joker another show that had to
follow in the footsteps of Batman the
Animated Series was Batman The Brave and
the bold which decided to embrace the
characters lighter Silver Age phase from
the comics of the 50s and 60s this Joker
which was voiced by Jeff Bennett's
looked a lot like the work of legendary
Batman artist that dick sprang and
really shined in stories like the
alternate world tale of earth 3 where a
heroic version of the Joker became the
last superhero on earth under the name
of the Red Hood whoever he is I hope my
apart on your world will have a chance
to repay you somehow that seems unlikely
Batman 89 Joker Jack Nicholson's
performance as the Joker and Tim
Burton's 1989 Batman movie is pretty
fantastic on almost every level he's
certainly the best part of the movie
with Nicholson's already creepy grin
accentuated by caked on makeup and some
truly amazing fashion choices and the
scene where he trashes an art museum
might be the most baller thing a super
villain has ever done the only problem
with this version of Joker is his alter
ego Jack Napier in the comics a big part
of Joker's origins is the idea that some
fundamental change in his personality
occurred when he fell in that vat of
acid here though he's pretty much
already the Joker he even carries a deck
of cards with him and he's obviously a
criminal and that undermines his arc
otherwise though it's totally awesome
Batman under the Red Hood even if you
don't recognize his name you're almost
certainly familiar with John DiMaggio
from his roles as bender on Futurama
Jake the dog on adventure time and
Aquaman on Batman The Brave and the bold
in 2010 he landed the role of the Joker
in under the Red Hood and he didn't
disappoint delivering a joker who
delivers every line as though it is an
actual joke giving you the sense of
someone who genuinely thinks that
beating someone to death with a crowbar
is hilarious it's memorable in the
creepiest of ways so let's try and clear
this up okay pumpkin Batman 66 Joker
pretty much everything about Cesar
Romero's portrayal of the Joker on the
1966 Batman TV show is great from the
way he attacks every scene with Monica
scenery-chewing Glee - the way he twists
has painted on grin into a disappointing
scowl when he's inevitably defeated all
the way down to the fact that Romero
refused to shave his mustache for the
part instead taking on the clown makeup
and leaving it completely visible in
every episode there's a panache and even
a little Menace to the role that makes
him one of the show's most memorable
characters
[Music]
unfortunately the show's writers were
bigger fans of the penguin and Catwoman
and Romero often got stuck in boring and
forgettable stories which didn't allow
him to really shine a true shame Lego
Batman movie Joker of all the Joker's
appearances across movies and TV who
would have expected that the one that
really went into whether his motivation
stems from a twisted sort of love would
be the one based on building block toys
for tiny children and yet here we are in
a world where that's just not
acknowledged in the Lego Batman movie
but serves as a driving force for the
entire plot Zach Galifianakis nails the
voice work to making this modern Joker
one of the best ever you're obsessed
with me no I'm not yes you are no I'm
not who else drives you to one-up them
the way that I do Bane the Dark Knight
Joker between the massive initial hype
and the outpouring of grief of following
the untimely death of actor Heath Ledger
it can be a little difficult to judge
his performance as the Joker on its own
merits but when you put aside all the
baggage and really look at it the truth
becomes clear it really is that good The
Joker of The Dark Knight is both
terrifying and genuinely funny but more
than that he's got an air of mystery
that's almost impossible for a character
so well known to cultivate with
virtually every line he delivers turning
out to be a carefully conceived
manipulative line he is one truth you
can bank on though Ledger's Joker is one
of the most influential and iconic movie
villains of all time but he's still not
the best Joker of all time Batman the
Animated Series Joker when you get right
down to it Batman the Animated Series
did everything right the slick stylish
take on the Caped Crusader boiled
everything down to essentials and no
carrots have benefited as much as the
Joker the Joker was frightening and
funny with a sweeping theatricality that
came directly from Mark Hamill's amazing
turn providing his voice
[Music]
[Laughter]
and the desire to give Hamill's Joker
even more to do directly led to the
creation of Harley Quinn who has gone on
to become one of DC's most popular
characters add it all up and the
animated series Joker remains a
definitive take on the character and
that's no joke thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]